Competition.
It's a fundamental part of human nature.
I was a professional
poker player for 10 years,
so I've very much seen all the good,
bad and ugly ways it can manifest.
When it's done right,
it can drive us to incredible feats
in sports and innovation,
like when car companies compete
over who can build the safest cars
or the most efficient solar panels.
Those are all examples
of healthy competition,
because even though individual
companies might come and go,
in the long run,
the game between them
creates win-win outcomes
where everyone benefits in the end.
But sometimes competition is not so great
and can create lose-lose outcomes
where everyone's worse off than before.
Take these AI beauty filters, for example.
As you can see, they're a very
impressive technology.
They can salvage almost any picture.
They can even make Angelina
and Margot more beautiful.
So they're very handy,
especially for influencers who,
now, at the click of a button,
can transform into the most beautiful
Hollywood versions of themselves.
But handy doesn't always mean healthy.
And I've personally noticed
how quickly these things can train you
to hate your natural face.
And there's growing evidence
that they're creating issues
like body dysmorphia,
especially in young people.
Nonetheless, these things are now
endemic to social media
because the nature of the game demands it.
The platforms are incentivized
to provide them
because hotter pictures means
more hijacked limbic systems,
which means more scrolling
and thus more ad revenue.
And users are incentivized to use them
because hotter pictures
get you more followers.
But this is a trap,
because once you start using these things,
it's really hard to go back.
Plus, you don't even get a competitive
advantage from them anymore
because everyone else
is already using them too.
So influencers are stuck
using these things
with all the downsides
and very little upside.
A lose-lose game.
A similar kind of trap is playing out
in our news media right now,
but with much worse consequences.
You'd think since the internet came along
that the increased competition
between news outlets
would create a sort of positive spiral,
like a race to the top of nuanced,
impartial, accurate journalism.
Instead, we're seeing a race to the bottom
of clickbait and polarization,
where even respectable papers
are increasingly leaning
into these kind of low-brow
partisan tactics.
Again, this is due to crappy incentives.
Today, we no longer just read our news.
We interact with it
by sharing and commenting.
And headlines that trigger
emotions like fear or anger
are far more likely to go viral
than neutral or positive ones.
So in many ways, news editors
are in a similar kind of trap
as the influencers,
where, the more their competitors
lean into clickbaity tactics,
the more they have to as well.
Otherwise, their stories
just get lost in the noise.
But this is terrible for everybody,
because now the media get
less trust from the public,
but also it becomes harder and harder
for anyone to discern truth from fiction,
which is a really big problem
for democracy.
Now, this process
of competition gone wrong
is actually the driving force
behind so many of our biggest issues.
Plastic pollution,
deforestation,
antibiotic overuse in farming,
arms races,
greenhouse gas emissions.
These are all a result
of crappy incentives,
of poorly designed games
that push their players --
be them people, companies
or governments --
into taking strategies and tactics
that defer costs and harms to the future.
And what's so ridiculous
is that most of the time,
these guys don't even want
to be doing this.
You know, it's not like
packaging companies
want to fill the oceans with plastic
or farmers want to worsen
antibiotic resistance.
But they’re all stuck
in the same dilemma of:
"If I don't use this tactic,
I’ll get outcompeted
by all the others who do.
So I have to do it, too.”
This is the mechanism
we need to fix as a civilization.
And I know what you're probably
all thinking, "So it's capitalism."
No, it's not capitalism.
Which, yes, can cause problems,
but it can also solve them
and has been fantastic in general.
It's something much deeper.
It's a force of misaligned incentives
of game theory itself.
So a few years ago, I retired from poker,
in part because I wanted to understand
this mechanism better.
Because it takes many different forms,
and it goes by many different names.
These are just some of those names.
You can see they're a little bit
abstract and clunky, right?
They don't exactly roll off the tongue.
And given how insidious and connected
all of these problems are,
it helps to have a more visceral way
of recognizing them.
So this is probably the only time
you're going to hear
about the Bible at this conference.
But I want to tell you
a quick story from it,
because allegedly,
back in the Canaanite days,
there was a cult who wanted
money and power so badly,
they were willing to sacrifice
their literal children for it.
And they did this by burning
them alive in an effigy
of a God that they believed
would then reward them
for this ultimate sacrifice.
And the name of this god was Moloch.
Bit of a bummer, as stories go.
But you can see why it's an apt metaphor,
because sometimes we get so lost
in winning the game right in front of us,
we lose sight of the bigger picture
and sacrifice too much
in our pursuit of victory.
So just like these guys were sacrificing
their children for power,
those influencers are sacrificing
their happiness for likes.
Those news editors are sacrificing
their integrity for clicks,
and polluters are sacrificing
the biosphere for profit.
In all these examples,
the short-term incentives
of the games themselves are pushing,
they're tempting their players
to sacrifice more and more
of their future,
trapping them in a death spiral
where they all lose in the end.
That's Moloch's trap.
The mechanism of unhealthy competition.
And the same is now happening
in the AI industry.
We're all aware of the race
that's heating up
between companies right now
over who can score the most compute,
who can get the biggest
funding round or get the top talent.
Well, as more and more companies
enter this race,
the greater the pressure for everyone
to go as fast as possible
and sacrifice other important stuff
like safety testing.
This has all the hallmarks
of a Moloch trap.
Because, like, imagine you're a CEO
who, you know, in your heart of hearts,
believes that your team is the best
to be able to safely build
extremely powerful AI.
Well, if you go too slowly,
then you run the risk of other,
much less cautious teams
getting there first
and deploying their systems
before you can.
So that in turn pushes you
to be more reckless yourself.
And given how many different
experts and researchers,
both within these companies
but also completely independent ones,
have been warning us
about the extreme risks of rushed AI,
this approach is absolutely mad.
Plus, almost all AI companies
are beholden to satisfying
their investors,
a short-term incentive which, over time,
will inevitably start to conflict
with any benevolent mission.
And this wouldn't be a big deal
if this was really just toasters
we're talking about here.
But AI, and especially AGI,
is set to be a bigger paradigm shift
than the agricultural
or industrial revolutions.
A moment in time so pivotal,
it's deserving
of reverence and reflection,
not something to be reduced
to a corporate rat race
of who can score the most
daily active users.
I'm not saying I know
what the right trade-off
between acceleration and safety is,
but I do know that we'll never find out
what that right trade-off is
if we let Moloch dictate it for us.
So what can we do?
Well, the good news is
we have managed to coordinate
to escape some of Moloch's traps before.
We managed to save
the ozone layer from CFCs
with the help of the Montreal Protocol.
We managed to reduce the number
of nuclear weapons on Earth
by 80 percent,
with the help of the Strategic Arms
Reduction Treaty in 1991.
So smart regulation
may certainly help with AI too,
but ultimately,
it's the players within the game
who have the most influence on it.
So we need AI leaders to show us
that they're not only aware
of the risks their technologies pose,
but also the destructive nature
of the incentives
that they're currently beholden to.
As their technological capabilities
reach towards the power of gods,
they're going to need the godlike wisdom
to know how to wield them.
So it doesn't fill me with encouragement
when I see a CEO of a very major company
saying something like,
"I want people to know
we made our competitor dance."
That is not the type
of mindset we need here.
We need leaders who are willing
to flip Moloch's playbook,
who are willing to sacrifice
their own individual chance of winning
for the good of the whole.
Now, fortunately, the three leading labs
are showing some signs of doing this.
Anthropic recently announced
their responsible scaling policy,
which pledges to only
increase capabilities
once certain security
criteria have been met.
OpenAI have recently pledged
to dedicate 20 percent of their compute
purely to alignment research.
And DeepMind have shown
a decade-long focus
of science ahead of commerce,
like their development of AlphaFold,
which they gave away
to the science community for free.
These are all steps
in the right direction,
but they are still
nowhere close to being enough.
I mean, most of these
are currently just words,
they're not even proven actions.
So we need a clear way to turn the AI race
into a definitive race to the top.
Perhaps companies can start competing
over who can be within these metrics,
over who can develop
the best security criteria.
A race of who can dedicate
the most compute to alignment.
Now that would truly flip
the middle finger to Moloch.
Competition can be an amazing tool,
provided we wield it wisely.
And we're going to need to do that
because the stakes
we are playing for are astronomical.
If we get AI, and especially AGI, wrong,
it could lead to unimaginable catastrophe.
But if we get it right,
it could be our path out
of many of these Moloch traps
that I've mentioned today.
And as things get crazier
over the coming years,
which they're probably going to,
it's going to be more important than ever
that we remember that it
is the real enemy here, Moloch.
Not any individual CEO or company,
and certainly not one another.
So don't hate the players,
change the game.
(Applause)